[music]
>> Well, hello everyone. Welcome and thank
you for coming to Vibe Once Run
Everywhere with Google's Anti-Gravity
and Flutter.
So, my name is Craig. I'm from the
Flutter Developer Relations team and
today I'm joined by Roddy from the
Anti-Gravity Developer Relations team
and Andy from the Anti-Gravity
engineering team.
Now, today we're excited to share with
you a lot of workflows that as
developers and builders you can add to
your toolkit to not only generate code,
but also work with non-coding assets,
generally reduce your toil, ship your
marketing materials, and more.
So, this session is going to be showing
all the ways that we're building with
agents. Ever since agents came onto the
scene, especially given how rapidly
models have been increasing in
capability and scope, there's been a
massive shift in how we utilize them in
the software development life cycle.
Anti-Gravity, as you might have guessed
on the title screen, is Google's premier
way to integrate agents into your
workflow.
Anti-Gravity launched in September and
it's an AI-native experience. While
there are plenty of other platforms that
you can choose from, Anti-Gravity is
trying to bring the best of Google all
into one place, integrating the agents,
tools, and workflows that you're already
used to. So, Andy, want to give us a
quick overview of Anti-Gravity?
Absolutely.
So, the spirit of Anti-Gravity is a
tight feedback loop between planning,
acting, and verifying.
So, to start off, after firing off your
prompt, Anti-Gravity can create various
artifacts as well as an implementation
plan, which you can iterate using the
model of your choice to really dial in
all of the details.
Once it starts working, you can also
always just step in and run the code,
test it out, read through the response,
or if you want to, you can let the agent
go ahead and build the entire system's
autonomously.
It's also inherently multimodal. We use
a lot of image generations, screenshots,
video recordings from the testing
process, and also surfacing a lot of
these all within anti-gravity, so that
you can review its work.
Once it's all done generating, the agent
can then decide what kind of artifacts
need to be generated, including coming
up with a plan.
Lastly, anti-gravity closes the loop by
confirming that complete the the plan
fully and correctly.
This includes running your app, taking
screenshots, and clicking the buttons
using Chrome's browser integration, and
of course, running your actual tests and
making sure they work.
And in Flutter's case, because Dart is
so strongly typed, it also includes
getting rock solid signal from the
analysis server, so that if there are
any problems, it can correct it, which
accelerates correct outcomes.
Now, obviously, this verification step
might bounce back to the act step as
necessary, since any failing tests or
broken flows, which feed back into the
agent, and the agent would then need to
make new changes into the code base.
Once it's all done, anti-gravity writes
up a walk-through what it did,
explaining what
explaining its implementation, as well
as the reasoning behind its decisions.
This loop powers the full gamut of
developer tasks, including testing,
debugging, migrations, deployments,
refactors, entirely new features, and
even non-coding tasks, which is a
growing use case.
So, this brings us to where it's like
building in 2026.
Google's models went through a
tremendous increase in capability around
December of last year, coinciding with
the launch of Gemini 3,
which has been in anti-gravity since day
one. When coding agents first hit the
scene, the focus was starting with
observation, and then we were reviewing
every step,
and every single line. But, as models
improved, the industry shifted towards
agentic engineering. Now, humans are
still in the loop and they focus on the
design and the lofty conceptual goals
over the small details.
And we can let the agents tackle the
individual components and going until
the product meets our specific
specifications.
But models still make mistakes and
that's why it's critical to have an
agent harness that allows you to review
outputs, quickly make changes, and
provide a direction when you're the
agent is unsure.
Antigravity brings the loop, but you're
still the human in the center of it. You
focus on your vision and what you want
to accomplish and let the agent help you
execute it.
A downstream outcome of this is that So,
we have new capabilities for developers,
PMs, and designers. And so, we're all
wearing new hats.
The roles are starting to blur.
While it might seem overwhelming
and you have this expectation to do
more, it actually empowers you to value
your colleagues time. Now, you can come
with a really strong prototype. A
designer can work on a prototype that
they give over to a developer and a
developer can have a first draft of a
design that a designer can take so much
further. This saves time and money.
There's a far less back and forth during
the prototype phase and instead of
struggling on describing your vision,
you can simply say, "This works and this
is where I'm wanting to take it."
If a picture is worth a thousand words,
then a prototype can save a thousand
meetings.
All right. So, that is a quick tour of
Antigravity. What about the other half
of the title, Flutter?
All [cheering] right.
Let's go.
Yeah, so Flutter is Google's
cross-platform UI toolkit. You may have
heard of it. And it delivers
pixel-perfect rendering across any
screen. Flutter delivers this by
rendering a canvas with the host
platform or operating system into which
it pours whatever pixels your app needs
from one frame to the next. And Flutter
is written in Dart, a language of
Google's invention, which originally
debuted in 2011, and which is a glove
fit for Flutter.
And Dart compiles down to native machine
code on non-web platforms or JavaScript
and Wasm on web platforms, which
delivers native performance anywhere
your Flutter app runs.
And Flutter and Dart also deliver an
outstanding developer experience,
including keystroke speed static
analysis on your whole project,
including very large codebases.
And stateful hot reload actually
accelerates agents just as much as human
agents or as human developers are
accelerated, rebuilding your app in less
than a second and capturing your heart
in far less time.
Now,
a lot of people might be thinking,
"Why bother using Flutter in this new AI
era if an agent can just write all the
code? Why not just have it write an iOS,
an Android, and a web project
separately?"
Well, that
is actually a pretty good question. And
it's one that I was thinking about
really hard last year when I was working
on the 2025 version of what's new in
Flutter, and it's what inspired a slide
that simply said, "Vibe once, run
anywhere."
And that answer is all about having a
single source of truth. If you have an
agent write a single cross-platform
application, then you naturally just
avoid all of the problems that spring up
from different language details or
different native feature
implementations. And then you also don't
have to spend the rest of your life
playing whack-a-mole chasing down all
the small discrepancies between these
different experiences.
And additionally, as Andy teased
earlier, Dart's strong typing gives LLMs
really great signal about what is going
on with your code. Now, languages with
looser typing systems often require a
lot more analysis from the LLM to figure
out whether or not a given piece of code
is correct in all scenarios. But,
Flutter is able to tell the LLM very
concrete things about function signature
mismatches, differences in class shapes,
or other objective facts about your
code. Now, you pair this with hot reload
and Flutter accelerates you
tremendously.
And with agentic coding,
time is money both figuratively and
literally. So, not only is Flutter able
to get to working code more quickly, but
then it doesn't have to start over and
do the whole thing again.
Truly, we think that Flutter's value
proposition is as strong as ever.
All right, but enough for all this
preamble, let's talk about what we're
building today. So, our goal was to
build a game where you pilot a moon
lander onto an asteroid. We wanted it to
feature dynamic things like procedurally
generated levels, custom shaders, and
particle effects. And of course, it had
to be fun and easy to play. Now, the
game is called Dash Lander, even though
we didn't have the heart to put Dash out
into the cold deep vacuum of space. But,
spoiler alert for later, I don't
actually know if we ended up delivering
on the easy-to-play part, especially on
mobile, but we can all figure that out
for ourselves at the end.
But, building the app is only part of
the story. There's not just code,
there's also marketing materials,
coordinating with the rest of your team,
and we are going to cover the full stack
of things today.
So, Roddy touched on this earlier, but
building apps today looks very different
from how we did it in the past.
Prototypes not only save a thousand
meetings, but being able to arrive at
one implies figuring what you want to
make, often by trial and error.
With tools like anti-gravity and Gemini,
you can make these wrong decisions
faster. You can try out different
techniques and figure out which paths
are dead ends and which one really
resonate with your vision, and get to
where you would have normally spent 6
months or over maybe a year on in a
matter of weeks or days.
And then, even if you decide to
completely rewrite your your code after
the MVP, the initial prototype still is
very very important because it helps you
crystallize exactly what you need to
build.
You've already done the wrong decisions,
figuring out what you want to build, and
with this fresh pair of eyes, agent
assisted or not, know exactly what you
want to build is really going to help
you get to your end vision faster. And
plus, you have this rich prototype that
you can pass on to the agent so that the
agent can always consult it for any
complex game logic.
But along with that, it's also important
to recognize what we're not building
today. So, we're not building a
high-performance real-time multiplayer
game.
And again, you might ask, "Well, why
not? Again, if agents can just write all
the code, make me a real-time
multiplayer game."
Well,
that's because
with real-time multiplayer games, code
is only part of the story. Networking
guarantees the introduction of some
latency, which doesn't really fit with
the experience that we were trying to go
for, to say nothing of the exponential
increase in back-end complexity that
you're signing up for.
So, instead, we realized that we could
deliver about 90% of that same kind of
fun multiplayer experience by just
having players face off against
historical sessions in like a challenge
mode from past high scores. And this
allows us to rely on very simple back
ends that don't you know, they scale on
their own, they don't make that our
problem, like Firebase hosting. So, our
app can now serve the millions of users
that we'll obviously be hitting it soon
without us having to have solved all
those problems. And this final design
was born out of failing fast because an
earlier version of Dash Lander did have
players battling it out with AI bots,
but then that was just really
complicated and we thought, "I don't
want to do that anymore." So, we leaned
into using AI logic that was just
written in all of our brains by having
people play against past sessions. And
that's the best code ever, code that we
neither wrote nor will maintain.
All right, onto phase one, research.
To make an asteroid Lander fund, you
obviously need assets.
We started out by using Google's Lyra to
make the background music.
And that works really great. We used the
audio players package to set it up in
the background, but then it was time to
start to make some more assets for the
game.
Obviously, there's things you can do
like public domain, but I wanted to take
it a step further. So, I literally went
in my garage and outside and I used a
hose to grab engine noise recorded with
a mic. And then I went and I finally
spray cans to get like the RCS
thrusters.
I had an idea and I was able to spend
more of my time working on real audio
engineering like I used to, but having
anti-gravity bring it into the game to
do a lot more of the fun. And I feel
like that's where I've really enjoyed
using this agentive coding.
But not just audio, we also need
visuals. And so, we used Stitch and
Gemini Canvas. Gemini wrote the particle
effects directly in the code and we used
tools like Nano Banana to generate the
app icons.
And of course, with a game like this, we
need physics. And so, we used Gemini
Deep Research, which we'll talk about in
a second, to be able to find the
accurate types of things we needed for
the things like the reaction control
system, the zero atmosphere physics, and
so many other things that were needed to
build a game like this beyond the
basics.
So, as Roddy mentioned, to to achieve
this, we used Gemini Deep Research. It
found the exact physics formulas we
needed to build this, which we then
transpiled into Dart with an
anti-gravity and included inside of the
code base.
Gemini Deep Research is also incredible
for doing some more research about
things you're curious about, such as
investigating product market fit, uh
investigating competitors, finding
potential pitfalls, and understanding
the market viability for Dash Lander.
So, once Gemini Deep Research uh
generates a lot of its findings, we can
then copy-paste all of that with an
anti-gravity.
So, now we'll move on to phase two,
which is the prototyping phase.
We actually started in AI Studio, which
is powered by anti-gravity in the build
mode now. You might be wondering, why
would we prototype something outside of
our build environment? Well, AI Studio
provides an incredible sandbox for
generating throwaway code rapidly. Not
only can we build something there, we
can share it with teammates, we can get
feedback from family members, and we can
have something where we're happy with it
before we start building the thing
that's ready for production.
We can get working concept without a
single line of code ourselves, and this
rich prototype acts as context
compression that we'll send to the model
later. And we can lock in all of those
micro-decisions early.
Once we're happy with the AI Studio, we
can just export it and move our code
directly into anti-gravity.
So, simultaneously, Craig was doing the
same prompt through Gemini Canvas, which
wrote another moon lander. But, his
version ended up not using the zero
atmosphere RCS controls that we were
looking for. But, his design came out a
lot more visually appealing. So, we end
up merging the best of both worlds and
had both prototypes that we used to
build our game.
Once we were ready to start working on
the Flutter Flutter version with an
anti-gravity, we equipped our agent
manager with the skills and the MCP
servers for the tech stack of our
choice. This Flutter uh Firebase,
there's a Flutter based game engine
called Flame, and then of course Gemini
API.
We were also able to add the entire
JavaScript code base into our repository
so that Anti-Gravity could reference it.
With all of our context and integration
set, we kick off the prompt to uh to our
agent so that it can build the Flutter
app.
Anti-Gravity can split the uh task into
multiple sub-agents, a feature where a
primary orchestrator agent is able to
delegate to multiple specialized agents.
So, as an example, you can have one
sub-agent working on the front end,
another one working on the back end, and
another one working on
internationalization so that everybody
can use your app.
Now, a quick piece of advice here is to
have a vision when you're working on
your task, and really feel free to push
back on the agent and guide it. So, that
if it's going in one way that you're not
a fan of, feel free to chime in and
correct it so that it really reaches the
vision that you had in mind. And this
really makes sure that you can download
the exact behavior.
And we certainly did this with
DashLander.
All right.
So, within about 5 minutes, we had
something that probably would have taken
us weeks to develop without AI, but of
course, it was not realistically
anywhere close to where we wanted it.
You saw a second ago that there were
only three hardcoded levels. That's not
nearly enough.
The camera is also not following the
lander right now, so you can play for
like a couple more seconds, and then
you're going to have a hard time.
These numbers in the HUD are also pretty
funky. If they're right, then the lander
is about the size of the Empire State
Building. So, that seems wrong.
It's also just really slow and terribly
boring, so that we didn't want that.
And then there was no leaderboard or
challenge mode yet. That one wasn't
really Gemini's fault because we had yet
to even conceive of the idea at this
time, so of course, that code had not
yet been written.
So, all in all, it would take about
another 100, 150 prompts maybe to get
the game where it is today. And a good
percentage of those, maybe about a
third, were all about code organization
and adding tests. Everybody has their
own personal relationship with reading
the code that you get from AI's these
days, but I like to maintain a sort of
kind of cognitive ownership over the
code that I'm working with. So, I read a
lot of what anti-gravity was giving me,
and I would often ask it to go back and
refactor things for clarity or
reusability.
Now, however,
this is just between us. Please, nobody
tell my old university, which once upon
a time bestowed a math minor on to me,
but I'm not very good at trigonometry.
And there is a lot of trigonometry in
Dash Lander. So, no matter how much I
would read that code, my understanding
stayed pretty much at zero.
And this was a problem because I
couldn't assess it, and whenever I would
play the game, things weren't adding up.
And then the agent would tell me, like,
"Don't worry, I have perfectly
implemented your landing scoring and HUD
metrics fixes." And then I would just
play it. It's like, "Well, it's not
adding up, so you didn't."
So, I added a debug mode where behind a
super top-secret keyboard shortcut,
additional overlays would appear in the
game and show me more kind of backstage,
like back of house information about the
state of the game. This allowed me to
inspect for myself with my own eyes, as
Darth Vader would say, what the what
like piece of land the game thought the
lander was over, the relative tilts
between them. Now, this was just a clip
of me flying into a cliff, so it didn't
really help me land the lander any
better, but it did help me squash a lot
of bugs.
And for that challenge mode that we
discussed earlier, we realized that
we're going to first need a leaderboard
so that we can actually point the game
at a historical session. So, I asked
Gemini to work on that feature, and it
did a really great job reading through
all of our code, our context, the
comments, and it even added new data
models that were suitable for
persistence. It connected the app to
Cloud Firestore, it started to read and
write documents from that collection,
and it gave us the screen
that we see right here.
But then, once I was able to start
playing the challenge mode, it like kind
of seemed like it worked at first, but
things were not adding up. There were
some logical mismatches that I had to
sort out.
So, here you can see a play-through that
I had against what was at that time the
highest score.
And the ghost ship is rendering nicely
here.
Uh it's a it looks just like us, but
it's a little see-through, just like I
wanted. And we're floating along, having
a good time. Little can you tell this
ghost ship is slowly starting to desync
from its original self.
And then, at the end, despite the person
having, you know, feathered back and
forth ever so delicately to stick the
landing just right, the ship ultimately
is going to come in
and not have a very good time and crash.
Which is happening in about three
two
Oh, no.
So, it's obviously something was wrong.
Now, for anyone who's seen my old talk
from FlutterCon Berlin a few years ago
called "A Year of Headaches: How Not to
Build a Real-Time Multiplayer Game", you
may know that I have already banged my
head against this very problem pretty
extensively.
And it turns out that despite capturing
the exact local time of every single
event in the game session, that is not
enough to faithfully recreate that game
session later on.
And the cause for this is that you can
tell a program to run a piece of code a
certain amount of milliseconds in the
future,
and that code will probably be run
really really really really really
really really really close to when you
asked, but it cannot guarantee perfect
accuracy.
And the reason for this, amongst other
things, is that code can't even
guarantee that it will have the
operating system's attention at the
given millisecond. This isn't Dart's
fault, it's not any other program's
fault, it's just an aspect of modern
computer architecture we have to build
around.
So, to solve this, I had to make like it
was 2023 and turn my own brain on and
think about things for myself. Really,
uh it was a blast from the past. The
solution I came up with was to store a
more complete representation of the
lander's physical state at the moment of
turning on or off any thruster.
In this way, when that replay logic is
chewing through the past events of the
previous play session, it can compare
the actual perfect values for where the
lander should have been with whatever it
is simulating in the present. And this
is important because that replay that we
were seeing, it's not a rasterized video
of the original session, it's another
simulation. But, if you're turning the
thrusters on like 1 millisecond early or
late, then you're going to get different
flight paths. And then Gemini, after I
had the idea cuz I'm so smart, did a
great job weaving into our code the
actual logic of comparing those things
and resolving different discrepancies.
And that fix ended up not creating any
visual artifacts at all, but it did
remove the problem of make-believe
crashes.
Procedural levels were very, very fun to
implement, especially because
anti-gravity and Gemini did such a good
job with the implementation. But, now
that we're done with that, we had this
new ambitious question in mind, which
was, "How is scoring going to work?"
Originally, our scoring system uh
rewarded points for conserving fuel and
also landing very gently. And that was
really easy to
to do if the landing pad is right below
your starting point. Um and after
extensive testing and lots of failed
scoring systems, um we decided we had to
switch things up a little bit because
otherwise you'd be incentivized to just
go straight into the the the landing pad
right below your starting point. So,
instead, we settled on assigning a score
multiplier based on different attributes
of how you landed into the landing pad.
So, the primary attribute is the
distance of your starting point to your
destination landing pad. So now, if you
start in a level where there's a landing
pad right below you and there's a
landing pad on the other side of the
meteor,
you would score more points if you went
to the other side of the meteor and
landed there instead of landing directly
below your starting point.
So, before pushing to the App Store or
to the Google Play Store, we chose to
launch this on web as a first MVP to
really validate and like test out the
core mechanics before we thought about
things such as integrating monetization
or like ads or like in-app purchases.
You might be great at writing games, but
you also may heart hate marketing them.
The good news is you don't have to do it
alone.
Using tools like Stitch or Gemini
Canvas, we can generate landing pages
from a single prompt. Stitch acts like a
design sandbox for rapid iteration. We
can simply take screenshots of a running
game and provide context about it as
well as generated App Store metadata,
and then just ask Stitch to build us
this marketing landing page.
Once the design is ready, we can
download the HTML into Antigravity.
And because we're building with Dart, we
can use Jasper, which is a web framework
that maps HTML directly to Dart widgets,
making the conversion seamless.
Gemini does a great job at mapping these
HTML into Jasper components since Jasper
components are just plain old HTML,
and they're not Flutter widgets.
This allows us to share code across our
game and app in case you need industry
standard web features like SEO indexing
or wanting to expose user-generated
content that you made within your
Flutter app.
I just love that it matched really well.
And now for the final phase, publishing.
All that's left is the dreaded problem
of figuring out how do you get this code
that runs on your computer to run on
somebody else's computer.
Luckily, with Flutter web and Firebase
hosting, this is pretty much solved
right out of the box.
So, this deploy script is quite simple.
We used Antigravity to build our Flutter
app, copy over its build directory over
to Jasper, run Jasper's own build
script, and then finally deploy all this
into Firebase hosting, all in one step.
And remember, this is Flutter. So, while
we stop short of the Google app uh Apple
App and Google Play Store's, you don't
have to. Flutter runs on a wide range of
devices from iOS to Android, the web of
course, all three desktop platforms. We
all know this. Embedded, but also the
new exciting esoteric places like
Toyota's RAV4 infotainment center, and
webOS for LG's hundreds of millions of
smart displays.
And in all of those environments, on all
of those screens, Flutter is going to
bring pixel-perfect rendering and
rock-solid performance.
And that's how you can vibe once, run
anywhere with Google's Antigravity and
Flutter.
I know this seems like a lot to take in.
What we wanted to show today is a
vignette of a modern builder's workflow.
Antigravity and Flutter makes the wide
open frontier easier to navigate, and
the landscape is yours to conquer.
Be sure to check out our resources and
code labs to get started. And yes, you
can even try out the game we built
today.
>> [snorts]
>> So, we invite you all to pull out your
phones,
visit dashlander.com,
or scan this QR code that hopefully
works,
and try for the highest score. The
mobile controls are a real work in
progress.
We're open to feedback.
It's much easier on a keyboard, so when
you get home, it's a lot more fun, to be
honest. Thank you so much for coming. We
cannot wait to see what you're going to
build.
>> [music]